right well border agents who were
accused of whipping migrants will not
face criminal charges do you remember
these images taken last september well
the biden administration including the
president himself and the press
secretary condemned those agents accused
them of mistreatment based on this
footage but it turns out after
investigation they weren't brandishing
whips or deploying them against people
those are rains used for controlling
horses but guess what now that no
criminal wrongdoing has been found we're
not seeing a whole lot of corrections
from the administration or frankly
the media
what do you think well when this
happened last year i was just horrified
right i have a family that
uses horses and horseback in order to do
their jobs it was clear from the
beginning that they were not whipping
any migrants this investigation was slow
walked by the administration and they
all of these agents deserve an apology
they've been on desk duty since this
happened and now that title 42 is going
to be lifted they need every able-bodied
person to be working look at what the
media did at the time check this out
i was not aware that whips
um which come from the slave era slavery
era were part of the package we saw that
image of at least one border patrol
agent using a whip potentially as a whip
even appearing to whip
these these uh people they deserve an
apology and i think it would do the
media a world of good to fess up here
and i would say the white house and the
administration needs to do the same
yeah brent hume here made that same
point earlier this week he said you know
these are border agents who serve in the
administration of president biden the
commander-in-chief called them out where
is the reversal on this we'll see if we
get one i'm steve ducey i'm brian kill
me and i'm ainsley earhart and click
here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis